hbo's succession is a great show about a
fictional media business
and there are some really interesting
scenes in season one that relate to
common real world situations
all of these clips come from season one
so if you haven't watched the full
season
there will be some spoilers in this
video you should go and watch it though
it's a really fun show and it's super
well produced
i'm john coogan and here's my reaction
to hbo's
succession now to be clear i've never
been on the board of a public company
but i have attended board meetings every
quarter for about the last decade
i've also never been involved in a
family business like waystar royco
in succession so i'm going to focus on
clips that i think generalize well to my
personal experience in startups
first up is a scene from the pilot
season 1 episode 1
celebration in this scene kendall roy is
trying to make a name for himself at the
company
by acquiring a small digital media
startup let's take a look at how he acts
during the deal
hey hey hey buddy good to see you
so we ready to [ __ ] you up
yeah okay look
i'm really sorry but it looks like
there's an issue
come on i came all the way up here dude
yeah i'm sorry
uh dude
okay listen you know i love what you do
right
i mean i'd love to keep you and your
team in place lawrence
i think vaulter is the shiz where the
shiz
yeah what's it gonna take you want me to
i'm gonna send a vintage jaguar over to
your house today
i'll do it so first up he's very
unprofessional and super casual here
it's not uncommon for people to try and
be friendly during a negotiation
especially if the lawyers aren't around
and you're talking about a deal
just founder of founder but this clearly
backfires
you should always try and act as
professional as possible when you're
early in a deal process
selling a company can be very emotional
so having empathy for what the founder
is going through goes a long way
kendall is all about putting pressure on
the deal and he takes it a step further
later in the episode the number is 140
cash with a stock alternative
you're on our board take the stock
you'll own a nice piece of us
well that is an appealing package
it is yeah it's appealing easy you still
need me to recommend this
no i don't this is a deal so [ __ ]
good you have to take it
or we'll see you in court dude
raising the acquisition price is a great
way to get a deal done if you are
struggling to find a shared vision
at this point it looks like kendall has
offered a high enough price that the
investors basically can't say no
now there is one oddity here he says if
you don't take the deal
we'll see you in court generally if a
founder blocks a deal
that would benefit the shareholders they
can't really be sued by the company
that's trying to acquire them
they could get sued by the shareholders
since all board members
including founders have a fiduciary duty
to shareholders
but if westar royco doesn't own any
shares in the target company
they can't really sue them for turning
down the deal applying pressure to close
an acquisition
does happen though usually it just takes
the form of threatening to launch a
competing product
this is what happened when facebook
acquired instagram kevin systrom the
founder of instagram
asked a friend who knew mark zuckerberg
personally what would happen if
instagram turned down facebook's
acquisition offer
system's friend said that zuckerberg
would quote go into destroy mode
direct competition like that can be
really scary for an early stage startup
so that's usually where the pressure
gets applied the second scene i want to
cover is from episode 6
which side are you on kendall is trying
to mount a coup
and get the board to issue a vote of no
confidence
boardroom conflicts are already
extremely dramatic but the writers
heighten
everything by making kendall run late
for the meeting one of his allies tries
to stall for time
let's take a look it's 12 noon
and i'd like to call the meeting of
waystar
royco to order roll call what
logo roy yeah you're here done roll call
what is wrong we're doing it today
why are we doing roll calls because
that's how we do it right noah
so logan roy is here
frank vernon present kendall roy
absent roman roy yo
a formal roll call like this is
basically unheard of and it's a pretty
blatant attempt to stall for time
usually the lawyers who are taking
minutes at the meeting would just look
around the room and make a note in the
minutes of who is in attendance
if your lawyers are formally calling
roll they're probably just trying to pad
out their timesheets and bill you more
just don't do it every company usually
has a set of rules that govern who can
call a board meeting and under what
circumstances
special meetings can be called so this
vote of no confidence doesn't
necessarily have to take place at this
particular meeting
but there are some restrictions usually
you would need the majority of the board
to agree to a meeting and schedule it a
few days in advance
each meeting requires a quorum for any
decisions to be legally valid
this prevents a situation where a board
waits until a particular board member is
traveling internationally without cell
phone service
and then calls a meeting instantly and
makes decisions without them
this is kind of a spoiler but the coup
fails and kendall is immediately fired
i'm chairman casting vote i win it's
[ __ ] over
what's the vote my son
that was your best shot you lost i think
there's some doubt as to whether he lost
one
kendall frank asha alona off the board
fired with immediate defense i don't
think you're able to security i am in
the middle of turning a [ __ ]
house you're what i call security i have
some doubt i'm in the middle
of turning up tanker
now a ceo logan roy can fire any members
of the management team
so it's very realistic that he would
fire kendall on the spot for leading the
coup
what's a little odd is that he also
fires several other board members at the
same time
typically board members earn their seats
through investments
and the investment firm they represent
is actually legally entitled to a seat
a good example of this in practice took
place during the uber controversy of
2017.
after facing a number of metoo related
culture issues
uber held a company-wide meeting where
the board presented
their thinking about a way forward at
the meeting david bonderman
an uber board member and a partner at
the private equity firm tpg
made some impolite remarks about women
and was quickly pressured to resign
but tpg still had rights to the board
seat so they installed david trujillo as
bonderman's replacement
replacing a board member who represents
a financial firm will not
likely change the way that seat votes on
important issues
and if you're an independent director
who can be removed by the chairman at
any time
it would be extremely difficult to vote
against that chairman so
this scenario is a little odd to me the
last clip i want to talk about
is from episode 8 prague in this scene
kendall is trying to rebound from his
firing at waystar
by getting into startup investing he's
clearly out of his element and it really
shows when he goes to pitch an art
dealing startup called dust
handle this is dust hey
great to connect love the name by the
way very
funky uh sorry please excuse captain
beef up here hey
how's it going how's it going cool
earrings very uh bauhaus
big fan of what you guys do sweet chili
sauce
thanks uh likewise
angela you want to spin us through the
pitch deck sure
so that's okay i don't need to hear the
pitch i've been through the deck
and uh i get it basically uh you buy a
painting from
some art student in a basement jack up
the price sell it to some morgan stanley
sex pest and you me and the student i'll
get rich right
we're interested in increasing the reach
of young artists
and the democratization of art no
absolutely
i get it you're uh providing a platform
to marginalize talent that the next
generation
of artists i'm just telling you how it
works from the
outside to the sharks most founders tend
to really believe in their missions
so coldly describing how you could
hollow that mission out
and focus purely on profits is never a
good strategy for an early stage
investor
it's fine to talk about how the business
model will evolve after all most
founders of for-profit companies want to
build companies
that fulfill their missions while making
money but ignoring the real world impact
that a startup can have is a big mistake
the bigger issue here to me is that
kendall is clearly trying to
self-actualize through his startup
investing
and that's never a good sign jeff lewis
the founder of bedrock capital
has a great youtube clip describing why
this is so important
you want to work with a vc who is not
trying to self-actualize
through investing in you and this is
basically the number one vector
on which you want to optimize for when
you're selecting a venture capital
partner
it's not firm brand it's not value ad
it's not
track record it is someone who seems as
if they are self-actualized
and does not need their investment in
your company to be a mechanism
for them to self-actualize why is that
because it's basically impossible to
self-actualize through making an
investment
okay so there are lots of ways to
self-actualize in the world
but core to self-actualizing means being
in control
of whatever the vector of
self-actualization is so
if if you're an entrepreneur you can
self-actualize through building your
company
if you're a vc who's founded your own vc
firm you can self-actualize through that
but you can't self-actualize through
writing someone a check and giving them
advice
investors who haven't built anything for
themselves can wind up exerting too much
control
because they want your company to be the
thing that they are personally known for
and that's never good
later in the episode the founder of dust
explains why she is turning down
kendall's investment offer
what happened he told me i'm sorry it's
nothing personal
i i shouldn't be telling you this but
i'm about to land a chunk of seed
capital the size of
like idaho so i mean whatever it is you
need
i can make it happen okay yeah okay
okay so are we good
you know it's just not about that
then like help me out here because
there's something i'm not seeing
it's the name which you mean dust
roy dendelroy it'd be like i was
marrying hitler and then i'd get to be
what mrs hitler
okay uh that's not really fair i mean
look that's that's not me i'm not
a roy well i would personally avoid
working with kendall in this situation
because he doesn't seem like a
self-actualized vc
and would probably be overbearing the
founder cites
the business practices and controversial
political leanings of waystar as the
determining factor
political alignment is increasingly
becoming a reason why founders choose to
work with specific vc firms
shortly after the storming of the united
states capital i saw a tweet by hunter
walk
who runs the seed stage firm homebrew
advising entrepreneurs
to not take money from jared kushner who
serves as a senior advisor to president
trump
who is his father-in-law not all
founders will have the luxury of turning
investors away based on their political
beliefs
but it's not unreasonable to try and
find venture capitalists who see eye to
eye with you on how the future should
unfold
politics continues to dominate every
aspect of public life
and you don't want your board meetings
to turn into political debates
that just won't be productive but what
do you think did you enjoy succession
let me know in the comments if you've
seen the show and what you liked about
it
and if you enjoyed the video please
consider subscribing to the channel
thanks for watching